تقوم مجموعة من 125 ضابطة شرطة أفغانية
بتحكيم النشطاء حتى
راكبي الدراجات المحترفين وعائلاتهم الذين
يحاولون إيجاد مخرج عن طريق البر أو
الجو
والبقاء في منازل آمنة سرية على طول
الطريق لبعض جوازات السفر الجديدة التي صنعها
الدبلوماسيون الأفغان في الخارج والتي تم نقلها إلى
البلاد الآن.  ضباط الشرطة السابقين
هوياتهم المخفية بسبب مخاوف تتعلق بالسلامة
تصف جزءًا من محنتهم أثناء
الاختباء
كنا نختبئ في موقع مع
120 شخصًا آخرين ولكن تم اكتشاف الموقع من
قبل
طالبان ودرسنا لمدة 18 عامًا وساعدنا
في تجنيد النساء في
الشرطة
كان هدفنا هو تحسين إمكانات
النساء وزيادة أعدادهن في
صفوف قوات الأمن
بشكل عام ، لقد عملنا بجد من أجل
أفغانستان ، ولكن الآن تم أخذ هذه الفرصة
منا ،
فقد أصبحت الرحلة الغادرة بالفعل
أكثر خطورة بسبب
جنسية رجال الإنقاذ من
أجل المنظمات غير الحكومية الإسرائيلية في إسرائيل ، كان هذا هو الإجلاء الثاني
من أفغانستان في  شهر
بقيادة جوتان بوليتسر الذي نسق
عمليات الإنقاذ من دولة مجاورة
لم تكن إسرائيل قد نفذت من قبل مثل
هذه العملية الطموحة للإنقاذ بالطريقة التي
اجتمعت بها جميعًا لم تكن جيدة جدًا
كما لم يكن مخططًا لها ، فقد كان كل نوع من
الاستجابة الطارئة بعد
يومين مرهقين من محاولة
عبور أماكن مختلفة بما في ذلك
بعض المواقف الشديدة للغاية حيث
كانت المجموعة محاطة بطالبين
قررنا أن المخرج الوحيد هو في
الواقع رحلة عبر
المطار الشمالي في أفغانستان عبر مزار
شريف
ولكن التفاوض مع طالبان
للمغادرة  كانت أفغانستان جزءًا فقط من
المعركة التي احتاجوا إليها بلدًا مجاورًا
طُلب منا عدم ذكر اسمه
للعبور من خلاله ، ودولة ثالثة
يمكن أن تُعقد فيها المجموعة قبل
إعادة التوطين في نهاية المطاف ، حيث قامت مجموعة
من النشطاء المتبرعين الأثرياء
بسحب كل خيط ممكن  الأشخاص
الذين تمكنوا من مجرد التقاط
الهاتف والاتصال بهذا الرئيس أو الاتصال بهذا
الرقم  وزير الخارجية
والتأثير عليهم على الفور لفتح حدودهم
، انتهى الأمر بالمجموعة الأولى التي خرجت منها إسرائيل
من راكبات الدراجات
وأعضاء فريق الروبوتات في الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
وهو أمر ربما لم يكن
ممكناً حتى قبل بضع سنوات فقط
وزارة خارجية إماراتية  احتفل المتحدث الرسمي
بوصولهم في العملية المشتركة
مع الإسرائيليين على تويتر ،
كيف أثرت اتفاقات إبراهيم على
قدرتك على العمل مع الإماراتيين ،
وأعتقد أنها تأثرت تمامًا.
شراكة خاصة ، لقد قدروا حقًا
حقيقة أنها كانت
بمثابة أول مهمة إنسانية مشتركة
وفي الكثير من محادثاتنا مع
مسؤولين حكوميين رفيعي المستوى حقًا
قالوا إنهم يريدون فعل الكثير مما
لا يمكن أن يحدث أي من عمليات الإنقاذ هذه
دون بعض الجدية  الدعم المالي
الذي جاء الكثير منه من
مؤسسة عائلية مجهولة والملياردير الكندي الإسرائيلي
سيلفان آدمز
متعطشا  شعر راكب الدراجة آدمز أنه ينجذب
بشكل خاص إلى زملائه من ذوي العجلتين
الكثير من الناس ولكن على وجه التحديد النساء
اللواتي
حصلن على طعم
الحرية والانفتاح
بما في ذلك ركوب دراجتك واليوم
سيتعرضن للاضطهاد وربما يفقدن
حياتهن لمجرد ركوبهن
الدراجات وبصفتي يهوديًا ، يقول إنه من
واجبه المساعدة حيث
يمكنه الحصول على
هذه الضرورة الثقافية القديمة ، فمن
واجبي أن أحاول ممارسة tikkun
olam
لتحسين عالمنا
حتى أشارك في المواقف التي
أعلم فيها أنني محظوظ لأكون قادرًا  للمساعدة
بعد رحلة استغرقت خمسة أيام ، وصلت المجموعة الثانية
إلى ألبانيا أثناء
استضافتها حتى إعادة التوطين hadas gold
cnn tel aviv